you know you what's happening I don't
know someone say shot fire I had uh two
twice two
t Greenland the largest island in the
world a nice desert at the mercy of the
ocean lashed by Arctic winds populated
by Seals and polar bears where time
seems to have stop flowing but beyond
that what do we really know about
Greenland we came here with very
specific purposes to dispel hard to die
myths to tell you the parable of an
inhospitable land shaped by Colonial
domination that aspires to be a nation
to show you how this is not just a white
spot drawn on a map but rather a part of
our history as human beings welcome to
[Music]
Greenland
for nearly four centuries settlers
traded wall Rus tasks and seal skins
with Iceland and Norway in exchange for
food wood and iron tools at the time
however the Norse villages in Greenland
were already falling into a ruin within
a few decades nothing more was known of
the inhabitants the crown of Copenhagen
interested in keeping the Artic trade
routs active and hunting Wales in order
to undermine the then Dutch competition
tried to reestablish contacts with the
Lost Colony 300 years of inconclusive
Expeditions followed until in
1721 the leral pastor Hans AG landed
where the first Danish settlement in
Greenland would be born Good Hope Good
Hope
[Music]
since 1979 GB has been renamed nuk which
means cape and it's the capital of
Greenland at that time aged believed not
only that he would meet survivors but
also that these having been isolated for
centuries still preached Catholicism or
paganism and that they spoke as some
form of Old Norse heade was wrong the
Greenland coasts had now become home to
another people the
[Music]
Inu the term init in the singular inuk
means people and has replaced the
derogatory and erroneous Eskimos which
means those who wears no shoes these are
Arctic people descend from the first
Siberian men who migrated over the
Millennia to the Northern areas of
Alaska Canada and Greenland and have
always lived by fishing and hunting
animals such as polar bears seals
reindeer and whales today 90% of
greenlanders are Inu and largely speak
the catcit language which is completely
different from the European ones in some
Villages like inila on the East Coast
the hit have never abandoned their
roots
we live uh with my mother and father you
fish and hunt for living
yeah now uh I'm hunting for living in
the summer uh I'm a Bo driver with the
tourist your um work is it shared with
other people here town in the town
you're the only one no no many there are
many yeah Tully the most direct
ancestors of the init penetrated
Southwest Greenland around the 14th
century there is when the noric Atlantic
area was hit by a phenomenal climate
known as the little Ice Age which is
believed to have caused The
Disappearance of the Norse colonies in
GB Ed's mission was to convert the
locals which were perceived as Savages
it was a slow process hindered by the
presence of the Anga the so-called Inu
shamans who are seen as holders of
knowledge in both the religion and
medical fields however the Danes began
to populate the western coast expanded
gutb and founded the harbor of yakob
zown the modern IL
reset with the creation of the royal
greenlandic company in
1774 Copenhagen established a monopoly
aimed at acquiring in exchange for
coffee and tobacco meat leather and
handcraft products including Tupac Bone
statuet depicting demons from init
mythology thus by changing perspective
the units began to deprive themselves of
resources that had always been necessary
to their subsistence and excess Western
Market logic this trend was frowned upon
by Danish officials who feared that the
Inuits would soon lose their Essence and
therefore their usefulness furthermore
in 1814 Denmark was forced to seed
Allway to Sweden after being defeated in
the Napoleonic Wars and to rely only on
the Icelandic and greenlandic colonies
then the presumed desire to preserve the
init culture was accompanied by the need
to make it more efficient in 1835 the
Royal company suggested building wooden
houses to replace the traditional init
homes there is huts and summer tents
made of Bones and fabrics although
famous the igloos were nothing more than
shelters used for hunting and fishing
and although it is redundant to
underline it no no single Enoch still
lives in the igloo in 1856 the colonial
administrators decreed that each
settlement would have to elect its own
representatives in charge of supervising
the society however only the most
experienced Hunters could carry out this
task in other words the Royal company
delegitimized the angu the shamans and
destabilized a proven social structure
the same thing happened when Denmark
decided to claim greenand in its
[Music]
[Laughter]
entirety
shortly thereafter the advancement of
European claims on the Arctic rots and
the outbreak of the two World Wars would
have made Greenland geostrategic
potential evidence in 1941 with
Copenhagen occupied by the Nazi army the
Danish ambassador to Washington Henry
Koffman allowed the United States to
establish five temporary military based
on the island these gave an important
tactical advantage to the Allied Air
Force however once the conflict was over
the White House didn't give up in fact
the United States aspired to exploit the
island for an anti-soviet purpose and to
take possession of cryolite a mineral
use for for the manufacturer of
aluminium present on the south coast in
great secrecy in 1951 American Engineers
began to build a gigantic Air Base in
Tuli still operating today in 1968 the
crash of an American fighter caused the
dispersion of four tactical
thermonuclear bombs which exploded and
contaminated the entire Tuli area one of
the four Warheads is still missing today
but 2 years before this incident
Washington had decommissioned another
Secret Base Cam Century which was
supposed to host 600 nuclear missiles
capable of reaching Moscow these US
military projects forced the local init
communities to move even 100 km away at
the same time the noise and the clanks
of the machines irreparably affected
ecosystems that had until then been
immersed in silence in any case
Greenland's most important resource
Still Remains the sea how many hours do
you spend on the boat we don't know
sometime 10 hours sometime 4 hours
sometime only two 2 hours even in the
winter uh no in the winter we used to be
dog slave okay yeah already in the first
half of the 20th century in Copenhagen
they had noticed how the fishing of
shrimp hollyood Cod and salmon could
generate much greater profits than those
deriving from traditional seal or
reindeer hunting in 1953 driven by
decolonization the Danish government
elevated Greenland to the status of an
autonomous Province over the course of
20 years Copenhagen launched two
development plans called G50 and G60
aimed at modernizing the Island's
fishing industry and settlements these
welfare policies have certainly improved
the quality of greenlandic
[Music]
life
despite its obvious advantages
modernization BR about much larger and
more sudden upheavals than those
suffered previously the abolition of the
mon o of the royal Greenland company and
the construction of New Port facilities
removed the social role of the hunter
who until 50 years earlier Colonial
officials had considered the Pinnacle of
Eno Society to guarantee greater
productivity of the locals now employed
in the fish factories the urbanization
projects involved the forced movement of
thousands of people from the villages to
the new Urban centers inhabited this
time equipped with shops schools and
hospitals apart from from barracks and
wooden buildings nuk is today the emblem
of an accelerated development that
doesn't take into consideration the
lifestyle of the inits just think of the
so-called block P an abnormal ghetto
residential structure built in the 60s
now demolished which was said to contain
1% of the entire greenlandic population
thanks to the opportunities that opened
up on the island inits found themselves
busy with tasks they had never done
before however they were paid 25% % less
than D in the same positions to earn an
equivalent salary ANUK had to have lived
at least 10 years in Denmark economic
discrimination went hand inand with some
perverse intentions in 1951 the Danish
authorities took 22 init children away
from their families to send them to
Denmark and train them as the future
greenlandic ruling class this experiment
needless to say failed half of those
children died at a young age and half
were affected by mental disorder
between the 60s and' 70s under
government directives Danish doctors
placed intrauterine coils contraceptive
instruments in the bodies of
approximately 4,000 init women and girls
in doing so in just a few years the
greenlandic birth rate considered
excessively high at the time was HED the
criticism and discontent towards the
entire postcolonial system led to the
birth of the autonomous parliament of
nuke in 1979 greenand chose its current
flag in 1985 the same year it left the
European economic Community to protect
its Waters from the probable Siege of
foreign fishing boats in fact today
Greenland is not part of the European
Union and has enjoyed an autonomous
government since 2009 nonetheless the
fate of the largest island in the world
is undefined according to United Nations
greenlandic Society suffers from the
lack of adequate housing and Healthcare
facilities It suffers from an
educational system that allows young
people to emancipate themselves
in 2014 the nuke government created a
Reconciliation Commission in order to
heal relations with Denmark it will be a
long process that will require the
acquisition of Greater awareness both on
the part of the unit community and the
Danish authorities myself having LIF
here for nearly 1 and 1/2 years I've
only experienced like one episode of a
drunk person coming up and saying I
should go back where I came from uh I've
heard other stories where people got
confronted during a night out or at a
concert also being asked to go home but
I would say like in general people I
meet are very open and honest that's the
thing about freen Landing
people the wounds of the colonial period
perhaps have never healed did you hear
shotgun shots over there yeah okay two
times they're calling the police okay so
I don't I don't need to go there no
thank you for letting me know thank you
[Music]
okay sorry shot fire shot fire okay so
go away we okay should go
okay hi I don't hi hi
hi you know you what's happening I don't
know someone say shot fire I had two tce
two
tce
what's happening you still have aun he
still have a gun
[Music]
okay the lower social classes I think
most of the stuff that I experience
alcoholism is a big problem like the
social Evolution kind of happened too
fast so to speak uh a lot of people lost
their jobs because they had to be moved
out of the smaller cities into like Nuke
there are like a couple of think we call
them the blocks at the you can't really
see them here like where people got
loded in together and I think forcing a
person who his whole life has gone
fishing gone hunting to suddenly work in
a factory is kind of soul sucking in a
weird way I could imagine that and also
having access to
alcohol kind of messed a lot of people
up I would
imagine the issues of greenlandic
society do not end here at all and now
more than ever in a 21st century marked
by uncertainty and competition between
Global Powers Greenland is destined to
deal with the inevitability of the
future and its challenges its
opportunities but we will talk more
about this in the next
[Music]
video
little